You could have implemented NSUserDefaults in a number of ways.
Here's how I did it. First I added a method to the app delegate to check if
this is the first time this app is run before. This is pretty much the same code
used in the example app.
The only thing I changed is what I said to be the default value. Here I set
float to be the default value for slider value key. Remember this is
important, so that you can check this user default throughout the rest of your
code, without wondering whether the value is set or not.
Next after looking around the PlaySoundsViewController
I thought it made sense to check for the slider value in ViewDidLoad.
And using NSUserDefaults floatForKey() method, I set the sliderView.value equal to
NSUserDefaults.standardUserDefaults.floatForKey(SliderValueKey).
SliderValueKey is just a constant that I used to store the key string I’ll be using
again and again. For saving the slider state, there are a few methods that would work.
If you save it in slider move
you will always be storing the most up to date slider value. If you stored in
play audio, you will see the last value that the user chose to listen to.
I chose to save it in play audio and I used
NSUserDefaults.standardUserDefaults.setFloat(sliderView.value, forKey:SliderValueKey)
to set the user default to the current sliderView.value, and let's run it.
“Is this a persistent yet?”
“I hope so.” “I hope so.”
And we see that the slider position is in the same place